مقتلوا علي حسن غالي مسؤول الوحده
الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس في غاره
اسرائيليه في خان يونس
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
يؤكد احراز تقدم في محادثات جده واشنطن
تؤكد ان الخيار العسكري ليس الحل
كيف تقول انها نجحت في اجبار الروس على
تراجع في باخموت والكرملين يقر بصعوبه
العمليه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الاهم الانباء من
العربيه افاد مراسل العربيه في قطاع غزه
بسقوط ثلاثه قتلى وعدد من الجرحى في قصف
اسرائيلي بمسيره استهدف شقه سكنيه شمالي
مدينه خان يونس وقتل في العمليه علي حسن
غالي مسؤول الوحده الصاروخيه في سرايا
القدس وفيما اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي استهداف
غالي في عمليه مشتركه مع جهاز الشباك قالت
حركه الجهاد ان الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه لن
تمر مرور الكرام مضيفه ان كل الخيارات
مطروحه على الطاوله
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
في الا
[ضحك]
براج
وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بين يمين
نتنياهو قال ان المعركه لن تنتهي حتى الان
مضيفا ان المعادله الامنيه الجديده هي
تحديد الوقت المناسب لاستهداف قاده
الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وندمر كل من يمس بنا او يعمل ضدنا هذا هو
المبدا الذي نتعامل به في اطار عمليه
الدرع والسهم اوجدنا معادله جديده نقول
للمخربين ومرسليهم نراكم في كل مكان ولا
تستطيعون الاختباء ونحن نختار المكان
والزمان الذي نضربكم خلاله نحن ولستم انتم
بهدوء وليس كرد فعل الخيار لنا انزلنا على
الجهاد في غزه اقوى ضربه في تاريخها
البيت الابيض اعلن ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاك سالفانت تحدث مع مستشار
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ساحل هناكبي بشان
غزه واشار سلفا الى ضروره استمرار الجهود
في المنطقه للتوصل لوقف اطلاق النار مشددا
على ضروره تهدئه التوتر ومنع اراقه المزيد
من الدماء كما جدد سليمان دعم الاداره
الامريكيه الحازم لامن اسرائيل وحقها في
الدفاع عن شعبها من الهجمات الصاروخيه
العشوائي
وسط التوتر وتصعيد بين اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه يشكو اهالي قطاع غزه من صوت
طائرات الاستطلاع التي يسمونها الزنانه
ويعتبرون هذا ديرشوم ومصدرا دائما للازعاج
والتوتر
[موسيقى]
انه صوت السائد في غزه على مدار 24 ساعه
وثقه المواطنون بهواتفهم منهم من وصفه
بصوت اللعين ونذير الشؤم واخر كتب اشعر ان
خلايا مخيت انفجر
صوت بشكل النخوه قلق صوت بيوحي بالحرب
بعدم الاطماني الاطمانينه هذه الزنانات
يعني بتغادرش الاجواء بالليل مرهقانا في
البيت في العمل في كل مكان
يعيش اكثر من مليوني غزاوي تحت رحمه
طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه يسمونها في
غزه الزنانه لما تصدره من صوت مزعج
وفي اسرائيل اسطول متنوع منها هيرمس وجدان
وايتان
منها ما يراقب ومنها ما يلقي بحممه بامر
من غرفه التحكم هذه
صراحه نفسها هذه ممكن تقتل وتؤذي وتدمر
بيوت زي اللي صار اللي في التصعيد اللي
احنا موجودين فيه الان نفسها هذه الزنانه
وهذه الطائره في نفسها اللي اطلقت على
البيوت زي البيت اللي في رفح بيت غنام
نفسها هذا صار في استشهاد لكل الاسره
صوت الزنانه يثير رعب غزه لكن صوت الصمت
يثير قلق اسرائيل
على الطرف الاخر انتظروا هذا الصوت صوت
صفارات الانذار لترد الفصائل بالصواريخ
حتى تنتهي جوله التصعيد ويعود لحياتهم
الطبيعيه
باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان خالد
عمر يوسف اقتراب مباحثات جده الجيش والدعم
السريع من التوصل للاتفاق يوسف اوضح في
تصريحاته العربيه ان ملاحظات جدا تسير
بشكل جيد بسبب وجود اراده للتوصل للاتفاق
بين اطراف الازمه مشيرا الى احتماليه
اتفاق الجيش والدعم السريع على انهاء
الازمه في اي لحظه كما اعتبر الناطق باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان ان الخيار
السلمي هو الحل الافضل للازمه التي تعيشها
البلاد
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
انها ستحمل قاده السودان مسؤوليه استمرار
العنف مشدده على انه لا حل عسكري للازمه
هذا وعربات الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
امتنانها للسعوديه على استضافه محادثات
بين طرفي الصراع في السودان
نعمل مع السعوديه للوصول الى وقف اطلاق
نار دائم في السودان واكدنا للشركاء
والحلفاء ان لا حل عسكريا للازمه نحن
ممتنون للسعوديه على استضافه محادثات جده
بين طرفي الصراع ونؤكد اننا سنحمل قاده
السودان مسؤوليه استمرار العنف
من جهتي قال العضو الديمقراطي في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي كريس هولند في مقابله
خاصه للعربيه ان مجلس الشيوخ يسعى لانشاء
ممرات الانسانيه في السودان لتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه للمدنيين وايضا اعاده
السودان الى المسار الديمقراطي
نحن نعمل بجدل انجاز شيئين واحد لانشاء
اماكن انسانيه في السودان حتى يحصل الناس
على الغذاء والقوت الذي يحتاجونه للعيش
وبعد ذلك نريد ان نرى وقفا طويلا لاطلاق
النار لاعطاء الوقت للمفاوضات الهدف
النهائي بالطبع هو اعاده السودان الى
المسار الديمقراطي حيث يمكن لشعب السودان
ان يقول رايه
وبالرغم من التطمينات والضغوط تواصلت
الاشتباكات ميدانيا بين طرفي الصراع وشهدت
عده مناطق في الخرطوم مواجهات عنيفه
استخدم فيها الطيران الحربي استخدم فيها
الطيران الحربي والاسلحه الثقيله
على اعتاب الشهر الثاني من المواجهات
العسكريه تتواصل الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع مدينه
الخرطوم بحري تصدرت المشهد بعد عمليه
عسكريه عنيفه حيث قرر الجيش مهاجمه مواقع
تمركز الدعم السريع هجوم الجيش في الخرطوم
بحري ياتي لمواجهه تمدد الدعم السريع
وانتشاره في المدينه فالمواجهه العنيفه
كانت في عده محاور لا سيما شامبات الحله
والبراحه وشرق النيل وشارع الانقاذ مقاتله
الجيش نفذت غارات على اهداف للدعم السريع
خصوصا في شنبات فيما قال الدعم السريع انه
سيطر على جسر الحلفايه شمال الخرطوم بحري
كما اعلن عن اسقاط طائرتين للجيش اما في
وسط الخرطوم تجددت الاشتباكات في مشنت
مقاتلات الجيش ضربات جويه استهدفت ايضا
محيط القصر الرئاسي
وفي ام درمان وقعت اشتباكات بين طرفي
الصراع وسمع ذوي قذائفي مدفعيه
لم يسلم المرضى من تداعيات الصراع في
السودان فبعد 28 هجوما على مرافق الرعايه
الصحيه في البلاد نجح العديد من المرضى في
الخرطوم الى مناطق اخرى ما سبب ضغطا وازمه
على مراكز غسيل الكره التي تعاني اصلا من
نقص الادويه مزامير محمد عثمان زار احد
هذه المراكز في مدينه بورسودان وعدلنا هذا
التقرير
مشاهدينا انا الان في مركز بورسودان
لامراض وجراحه الكلى من المعروف ان القطاع
الصحي من القطاعات التي تاثرت بشكل كبير
جراء الحرب بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
سنقف على ما يجري داخل هذا المركز على
اعتبار انه يحتوي على 30 ماكينه غسيل
لمرضى الكلى ان كان هنالك واحد من المرضى
من الخرطوم
يعني لاحد كان بغسل في مركز فضيل والمركز
بجف
ومشينا على مركز في ابو ادم
والمركز برضو وقف قمت اتحركت على اساسا من
بنات المنطقه اصلا
كم غسله في الاسبوع انا عندي غسلتين في
الاسبوع اربع ساعات اربع ساعات ولان الامر
عندي لا يرتبط بالمهنه فقط بقدر ارتباطه
بواقع انساني قد يتفاقم سريعا في هذا
المجال طلبنا من السلطات القائمه التدخل
وكانت الاستجابه سريعا بعد نصف ساعه ودار
هذا الحوار نحن يمكن اساعدتك عندنا طلبات
تخص الولايه هنا يعني زي مشكله المويه
المركز مع الضغط الكبير بتاع العينين
اضطرينا نفتح ورديات اضافيه بالتالي عندنا
اشكاليه في النوايا فمنحتاج منك انه
توفرينا عليه الاقل تنكرين في الاسبوع
ده يمكن الطلب ولا
بالاضافه لانه بالتعاون مع وزاره الصحه
تساعدونا في غير غير المستهلكات الاساسيه
بتاعت الغسيل الحاجات المعينه للغسله
الشايش والبطن والبلاصه المويه المحتاج لا
نحن
التزام يعني ابتدام في الكل اسبوع مرتين
احنا ملتزمين بها في كميه من الوافدين
للولايه وبالتالي الضغط على على المركز
كان كبير جدا جدا نحن ان شاء الله حنجيب
معاك في المزرعه دي وكل معيناتها ان شاء
الله مع الجهاز
هذه الولايه تعاني اشكالات كبيره جدا
تتعلق
بالمياه وبالتالي هذا يضع ضغط كبير جدا
على القطاع الصحي وبالتحديد على مراكز
غسيل الكلى هنا في هذه المدينه بورسودان
التي من المتوقع ان تستقبل اعداد كبيره
جدا من المرضى القادمين من الخرطوم محمد
عثمان لقناته العربيه والحدث من مدينه
بورسودان بولايه البحر الاحمر شرقي
السودان
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم من العمليه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا صعبه للغايه ونقلت
وكاله التاسعوف قوله ان تحقيق بعض الاهداف
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا كان
صعبا لكنه اكد ان روسيا نجحت في الحاق
اضرار جسيمه في الجيش الاوكراني واضاف
بسكوف ان بلاده ستستمر في العمل لتحقيق
اهدافها في اوكرانيا
من جهاته قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه انه هجوما مضاده لقواته نجح في
اجمال القوات الروسيه في بخموت على
التراجع وقال القائد العسكري الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه تراجعت لمسافه تصل الى
كيلو مترين في بعض مناطق بخموت هذا وكدت
مصادر ان التراجع تم من احياء في المناطق
الغربيه للمدينه
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
واشنطن تحشد اربعه وعشرين الف عنصر امن
على حدودها مع المكسيك تحسبا لتدفق المزيد
من المهاجرين
اهلا بكم من جديد
قالت وكاله الانبياء السعوديه ان الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز بعث دعوه الى رئيس
السوري بشار الاسد لحضور القمه العربيه
المقرره في جده في التاسع عشر من مايو
الجاري وسلم السفير السعودي في الاردن
نايف سديري الدعوه الى الاسد الذي اكد من
جهته ان انعقاد القمه العربيه المقبله في
الرياض او في السعوديه سيعزز العمل العربي
المشترك لتحقيق تطلعات الشعوب العربيه
ضمن البرنامج السعودي للتنميه ويعمار
اليمن قال سفيره السعوديه لدى اليمن محمد
الجابر في مقابله العربيه ان البرنامج
انجز المرحله الاولى والثانيه من تطوير
مطار عدن وبدا في المرحله الثالثه
والاخيره طبعا المطار عدن هو احد المشاريع
الكبيره جدا البرنامج ينفذها من المرحله
الاولى والثانيه واليوم وضعف اقامه الرئيس
المرحله الثالثه
فور انتهاء المرحله الثالثه سيكون المطار
على اعلى مستويات الدوليه وسيسمح لكثير من
الشركات
باستخدام المطار سواء في السفر من والى
مطار عدن هذا المطار هو ايضا هناك مطار
الغيطه ايضا وكذلك طريق العبر في حضرموت
ومارب 130 كيلو كذلك يجلس العبد في تعز
بالاضافه الى مجموعه من المشاريع النقل
الداخليه المختلفه في عين المحافظات
اليمنيه
يدخلون رئيس تركيا
في مواجهه تحديات العده وعراقيل صعب دفعته
البحث عن تحالفات سياسيه تعزز حظوظه للفوز
بولايه الرئاسيه جديده رواه حمزه
والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اختبار صعب يدخله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لتتويج عقدين من حكمه في ولايه
رئاسيه جديده واخيرا كما ينص الدستور يدخل
اردوغان الانتخابات بمواجهه سته احزاب
معارضه متحالفه ضده لكن العلاقه القريبه
التي اسسها اردوغان مع القطاع المحافظ تعد
اهم عنصر سانده في السلطه اضافه الى قاعده
حزبيه قويه حلفاء الرئيس التركي لجانب
حزبه العداله والتنميه هي احزاب صغيره
لكنها قد تحسم السباق الانتخابيه المتقارب
لتضمن له تجاوز عتبه الخمسين بالمئه في
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات منها احزاب
اسلاميه صغيره تجد نفسها تحظى بتاييد
متصاعد خصوصا حزب الرفاه الجديد ورغم ترشح
زعيمه فاتح البكان فانه عاد وانسحب واعلن
صراحه دعمه لاردوغان وكذلك يوجد حزب
الحركه القوميه المتحالف مع اردوغان وساهم
في اب في السلطه والحفاظ على اغلبيته
بالبرلمان ايضا من ضمن الاحزاب التي تحالف
معها اردوغان حزب الدعوه الحره ينتمي
مؤسسه عرقيا للاكراد ويصنفون ايدولوجيا
اسلاميين محافظين لذا يوصف الحزب عاده
بانه حزب كردي اسلامي
اردوغان رحب بدعم حزب الدعوه الحره حيث
يمنحه هذا الدعم فرصه للحصول على اصوات في
مناطق كرديه كان يخشى ان تكون سببا في
خسارته حزب اليسار الديمقراطي ضمن قائمه
داعمي اردوغان رغم العداء التاريخي فهو
حزب علماني اصيل كان للحزب ثقه له الكبير
منذ عام
1999 عندما حصل على 136 مقعدا في البرلمان
الا انه تدهور بعد وفاه زعيمه بولنت
اجاويد ولم يعد له اي مقعد ادراج هذا
الحزب رغم ضاله تاثيره يبرز غرابه
التحالفات التي دفعت تيارات
للاصطفاف اضطراريا رغم اختلاف
الايديولوجيا من اجل تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه
في مقابله خاصه للعربيه قال رئيس حزب
العداله والتنميه في ولايه اسطنبول عثمان
نوري كاباكتابي بانه اولويات حزب العداله
والتنميه في الانتخابات الحاليه وتذكير
المواطنين بان تركيا باتت تنافس الدول
المتقدمه في مجالات عده دون ان يتطرق الى
اعاده هيمنه التيارات الاسلاميه او
المحافظين على الحكم او الاقتصاد
كل انتخابات نخوضها تتطلب تجديدا وما
نقصده هو نقل تركيا الى مراحل متقدمه من
التطور فقد غدت تركيا اليوم دوله تصنع
طائراتها الحربيه بنفسها بعد ان كانت
تستورد حتى عجلاتها من الخارج ورفعت عدد
مطاراتها من 20 مطارا الى 60 وصارت تصنع
سياراتها بعد ان كانت تستورد اصغر
المنتجات الصناعيه وستغدو من الدول
المعتبره والمعدوده في التكنولوجيا الفضاء
والصحه وما وصلت اليه في التعليم نحن
واثقون من دعم المواطنين لنا في انتخابات
القرن التركي
[موسيقى]
وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده مددت محكمه
باكستانيه اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران ثمانيه ايام على ذمه التحقيق في
قضيه فساد
ومع تواصل الاحتجاجات العنيفه التي اعتقبت
او اعقبت اعتقاله طلبت الحكومه نشر
تعزيزات من الجيش للمساعده في حفظ الامن
والنظام
الازمه السياسيه في باكستان تزداد تعقيدا
محكمه باكستانيه تعنى بقضايا الفساد مددت
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران على ذمه
التحقيق لمده ثمانيه ايام ومحكمه اخرى
جنائيه وجهت لائحه اتهام له في قضيه فساد
تتعلق بالاستحواذ على هدايا بطريقه غير
قانونيه فيما نفت الحكومه اضطهاد عمران
خان سياسيا
عمران خان اختار طريقه تخريب في البلاد من
اجل التهرب من محاسبته بالفساد الحكومه لم
تامر باعتقاله وليس لديها تاثر سياسي معه
وانما اعتقل بناء على امر قضائي من مكتب
المحاسبه الوطني وهو مؤسسه مستقله وقد
اكدت محكمه عليا قانونيته
حزب الانصاف بزعامه عمران خان اتهم
الحكومه بتبني سياسه تعسفيه في اداره
الشؤون البلاد واضطهاد خصومها مشككا في
نزاهه محاكمه عمران خان ومجددا الدعوه
للتظاهر احتجاجا على اعتقاد رئيس الوزراء
السابق محاكمه عمران خان ترى فقط مع اعمال
شغب واحتجاجات نظمها انصاره في مناطق
مختلفه من باكستان كما ترافقت مع حمله
اعتقالات في صفوف قاده وانصار حزبه
حراكنا كان سلميا وسنواصل ذلك دعونا قضت
الحزب وفريقه القانوني لتشاور ورساله
عمران خان لكم استمرار الاحتجاج سلميا
وعدم اللجوء الى العنف
وبينما قررت السلطات الباكستانيه طلب
تعزيزات من الجيش للمساعده على حفظ الامن
والنظام ندت الجيش باستهداف بعض مقره
ومحذرا من اتخاذ اجراءات صارمه ضد مثير
الشغب
اطراف الازمه بمواقفهم يبدو ان المواطن
العادي سيظل يدفع فاتوره الخلافات بين
صناع القرار في باكستان عبد الرحمن
المزيني العربيه اسلام اباد
اعلنت وزاره العدل الامريكيه اعتقال عضو
مجلس النواب الامريكي عن الحزب الجمهوري
جورج سانتوس بينيويورك بعد توجيه تهم
بينها التزوير وغسيل الاموال وسرقه اموال
عامه والادلاء ببيانات زائفه وقال مدعي
عام المدعي العام الامريكيه ان
النائبراليه ولا تزال القضيه قيد التحقيق
اتهمت منظمات غير حكوميه فرنسا بارتكاب
انتهاكات جسيمه لحقوق المهاجرين على
حدودها مع اسبانيا التقرير الحقيقي اشار
الى ان فرنسا تعرض مهاجرين لنفس المعامله
المسيئه التي تمارسها على حدودها مع
ايطاليا
منظمات حقوقيه تتهم فرنسا باساءه معامله
المهاجرين على حدودها مع اسبانيا وايطاليا
بين 2019
و2022
رصدت المنظمات عمليات تفتيش تميزيه
واعاده طالبي لجوء من ذوي الملامح السمراء
تعرضوا للتنطيط العرقي والترحيل القصري
السريع حسب التقرير السلطات الفرنسيه شددت
المراقبه على 37 نقطه عبور الامر الذي دفع
بالمهاجرين الى المرور بمناطق واعره
المخاطر ادت الى مقتل ما لا يقل عن 12
شخصا
اعلن مسؤولون امريكان بلاده نشرت اكثر من
24 الف عنصر امن على حدودها الجنوبيه مع
المكسيك وذلك مع قرب انتهاء قانون تايتل
42 الذي يمنع تقديم طالب او طلبات اللجوء
للولايات المتحده كما يسمح بترحيل
المهاجرين الى المكسيك
قرار ترامب المثير للجدل ينتهي الخميس
قانون تايتل 42 سمح للسلطات الامريكيه
برفض المهاجرين المكسيكيين وذلك بحجه نقل
وباء كورونا للولايات المتحده عشيه انتهاء
القانون تكدس الالاف من المهاجرين على
الجانب المكسيكي من الحدود ما دفع
الولايات المتحده لنشر اربعه وعشرين الف
عنصر امن على حدودها ومن المتوقع ان يستمر
الامر كذلك لاسابيع
فالختام هذا تذكير بابرز العناوين
مقتل علي حسن غالي مسؤول الوحده الصاروخيه
في سرايا القدس ثغاره اسرائيليه في خان
يونس
وكيف تقول انها نجحت في اجبار الروس على
التراجع في ضخمه
نهايه النشره الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات